When it comes to consumer electronics or electric
cars, lithium-ion batteries are still the
technology of choice thanks to their high
energy density and decent charge times.
But billion dollar tech and auto giants are
betting that there’s still room for improvement.
One of the most promising upgrades has been
mired by a mysterious setback, but now researchers
think they’ve ironed out the problem, literally.
Scientists have been researching an improvement
to the battery’s cathode -- the positive
end -- for years.
The cathode is the most expensive part of
the battery, so research has been focused
on finding cheaper materials while improving
performance.
Your phone’s cathode probably uses cobalt
oxide, which are* great for small electronics
but too volatile and expensive for use in
electric cars.
Tesla’s secret sauce is a cathode made of
nickel, cobalt, and aluminum, which is designed
to reduce costs.
But for electric cars there’s a cathode
that could promise more range for cheaper.
It’s called the Lithium Rich NMC cathode,
and as its name suggests it’s made of layers
of lithium rich nickel, manganese, and cobalt
oxides.
The first generation of this cathode has already
been used, like in the original Chevy Volt,
but the second generation was projected to
nearly double the battery’s capacity up
to about 280 milliampere-hours per gram.
This was achieved by upping the voltage from
about 3.7 volts to 4.7 volts, but after a
few charge and discharge cycles researchers
noticed a steep drop in energy the new battery
could store and discharge.
They dubbed the problem “voltage fade.”
The problem appeared to be the materials in
the cathode scrambled when the higher voltage
was applied.
The manganese, nickel, cobalt, oxygen, and
lithium rearranged themselves and the material’s
new properties couldn’t deliver the performance
of the original structure.
While some scientists have deemed voltage
fade an intrinsic property of the material,
others aren’t quite ready to give up on
it just yet.
In July of 2018 researchers published a paper
in the journal Nature Energy that not only
pinpoints what causes the voltage fade, but
actually found a way of reversing it.
The researchers x-rayed the cathodes under
operating conditions and saw the nanoscale
defects forming in the otherwise perfect crystal
structure.
Once they knew exactly how these defects were
taking shape, they devised a heat treatment
to get rid of most of them.
When the treated cathodes were applied to
new batteries and tested up to 4.7 volts,
they performed like new and with no voltage
fade.
This doesn’t mean these new cathodes are
going to flood the market anytime soon.
The researchers stressed that this heat treatment
is labor intensive and can’t be applied
on a large scale easily.
But their work does keep the promise of these
better cathodes alive, and encourages more
research into solving the problem of voltage
fade.
I-T people know how it is.
When all those alerts and tickets light up
your monitor like a Christmas tree, you aren’t
being productive, you’re just stressed out.
No mere mortal can analyze all of those alerts
and respond to all those tickets.
Good news – you can immediately reduce that
noise with Moogsoft A-I Ops - artificial intelligence
for I-T operations that reduces your I-T alerts
and tickets by up to 90%.
Guaranteed.
Moogsoft’s A-I Ops platform integrates with
all of your existing I-T tools.
Moogsoft’s patented technology correlates
events into actionable work items called Situations,
so you can focus on tackling the stuff that
matters.
With Moogsoft A-I Ops you can reduce your
I-T alerts and tickets by up to 90% right
now.
Visit: Moogsoft dot com to get a demo.
That’s M-O-O-G-S-O-F-T dot com.
Moogsoft dot com.
While you’re here, subscribe because unlike
some batteries, we keep the energy flowing.
Like in this video where I talk about how
contact lenses could lead to better electric
cars!
The cathode in your phone battery is what
wears down too, causing a dip in performance,
though it’s not as sudden as these experimental
NMC cathodes.
Thanks for watching Seeker!